Markipler: Hello, everybody! :D
My name is Markiplier! And welcome to the video where I Google myself to see what the internet has to say about
my everyday lives.
Or at least what you guys wanna know-
so, I'm going to do this in a few ways,
I'm going to let Google decide what to autofill in the search for myself.
And then I'm going to... try to...
[inaudible gibberish]
It's a little bit- I don't know where it's gonna go with this,
but I'm gonna assume it's gonna go somewhere bad...
So let me just search up...
Markiplier... Just baseline.
Oh!
Ah!
Ooo!
So nice.... Oo! Cool!
Goodness grievous.
Oh, there's my search popularity over time.
Well, it peaked there, so I think we can all agree that's when I peaked...
And then I'm just-
I'm basically operating in 50% value.
Alright, this is pretty much what I expected it to be but I want it to be a little something,
more than this. So let's let Google decide Markiplier is...
"Dead"! "Dead", "Asian", and "Short".
"Markiplier is this the end"
What is that? "Is this the end?" Is this the end for all of Markiplier's HUNIE's?
Is this the end for all of Markiplier's HUNIE's?
Have I finally accomplished my goal of bumping glorious sexicles?
Tune in right now to find out!
(X-Files or illuminati theme plays)
(MLG version)
("It's Everyday Bro" remix plays)
People think that I peaked with Five Nights at Freddy's,
no, no,
I'd like to think I peaked with HUNIE POP
And I'm just waiting for the sequel to come out so that I can peak once more.
Markiplier is....
Dead. Oooooh,
good.
Markipiler is dead...
100% proof.
In-video Markiplier: You first want to start out by heating up-
*explosion*
*leaves from inside the video*
Right. Okay. Cool.
Markiplier is Asian, in case you didn't know,
Yes- *giggles* there I am! Yes!
I am Asian.
I am half-Korean.
It is- uh, mixed.
Markiplier introduces his extremely-looking Asian...?
Brother To-
What the fuck does that even mean?
- So I have some proof that...
Markiplier is just a big act. Just a big shtick. He doesn't really care about his followers.
It's a play. like- like no shame at all.
He's purposely trying to be funny, and it doesn't work cuz he just looks like a little bitch.
- He's just it's so sad to see how pathetic he is for money where he's all like-
Markiplier: [holding in laughter]
- "Oh I gotta make a funny face."
- He's just- he makes me sick.
Markiplier: I know this has to be a joke because there's- Look at the top left, in the top tab "free porn sex tube"(EXPOSED)
Merry Christmas, ob- oh.
Christmas!
Christmas Markiplier is awful!
- Okay, so I just wanted to say Merry Christmas to all my fans out there, and, a
Terrible fucking Christmas to Markiplier.
- I hope he got coal from Santa Claus this year and by the way if you notice something different
Markiplier: (laughter)
- I got a great awesome new microphone that my Mommy gave me and it sounds fan-tastic.
Markiplier: (more laughter)
- So yeah, Merry Christmas my fans and fuck you Markiplier fanboys and Markiplier,
Markiplier: Uuuuhhh… Fuck.
Markiplier: Yeah!
- So yeah, Merry Christmas my fans and fuck you Markiplier fanboys and Markiplier,
- hope you all die.
Markiplier: (laughter)
This is quality content! I- I want more of! *laughs* *Cries on the inside*
{just wanted to point out, I fixed the majority of the wrong subtitles from 0:00 to 3:27. No disrespect to the person who did the subtitles from here, but I just want to say there were a lot of issues and as you can see I've fixed them. I'll finish the rest of the subtitles from now on but I'm saving it here -Ijustgottabehonestbut}
Bystander: "You're so short! You're so short!"
"I know" (Mark on the inside: WHYYYYYY)
Let's go with something, a different angle to this. Is Markiplier
married
to Jacksepticeye (Kinky much?)
No thank you. How tall is Markiplier?
5'10" hell yeah
Markiplier, Dadio
There's my pictures of my dad
That's me and my brother. Oh look at us
Oh look at us we're so cute
Oh look at bee
Look at bee, oh my God
Markiplier crying, oh here we go.
Okay "Try Not to Cry Challenge"
Markiplier version, oh oh
Great. Oh, this is what we need. Oh, this is what we need oh
Great look at this bullshit here. I know what this, this is from my twenty thousand fan
Twenty thousand Subscriber fan video, and I just was
Balling like a baby
Well, it's not the first times I cried on camera, and it wouldn't be the last
Oh look at me, Oh of course it was Bob and then again just
Recently Bob on the tour made me fucking cry on stage like that asshole
He said that in no uncertain terms
he was just like "I know he doesn't need anything else to inflate his ego"
But he honestly and truly thanked me you know for bringing him on the tour, and I was like
"I'm fucking- come on dude I'm in front of people." Yeah.............
As if I haven't cried in front of like forever a fan-made subscriber
Milestone video apparently this one has over a thousand fans reacting to me reacting to something or other as with the six million
Oh, I should do another fan reaction video. I know I should I'll cry like a BATCH
Ill cry like a biatch. I cried so much more in this one than I did in this one
Hey guys is the lightly different video than what you're used to oh jeez that was I wonder if those
Other of those have they actually made another one yeah, I don't think that this video has ever come out. This is
It was originally markiplier sings badly, and now it's friends always mattered just to make it a rebranding. Which is totally fine
But then like this video was supposed to be the 10 million, Subscriber, Milestone
but then it came and went so fast and the the video got so
Ambitious that I think it just became harder and harder to manage
And then there probably was like a file loss or something
but either way if this video is still under way like because if you guys haven't seen the the the
you guys haven't seen the video and I know there are other reaction compilations here because even
the Fuck I
Didn't notice that before ethan you cunk. You come come come and bummer punch you so nice oh geez oh
Yeah, if this video is still under way in any capacity just please....
Let me see it. I would love to see it. I would love to react to it! <3
I would love to do another reaction video I
Don't even care if it's late. I don't I don't care if it's late. If it is that's fine
I I want to see it. I still want to see you. So please support
Markiplier Friends always Matter and
Anyway back to the whole reason I'm doing this which is google "fuck markiplier". This is one video for fuck markiplier: fuck you
hahaha
And fuck you
It's so shitty quality too I love it.
"Fuck you Markiplier" here we go. I'm ready
Hey Markiplier (Marky player), you're so stupid as fuck idiot, I hate your stupid fucking Mario games
What's up, *intelligible* how you doing today dudes?
Good so today. I hate- what's his name again, Mom?
I don't know Michael. You cannot be offending people on the-
on the videos.
You see about that choice
You see - is good very used to stupid chinese guy. It's just lets you know that the blue hair boy too far
Mom, try to be crazy with the guy.
look, I can go crazy like as....
AAHHHHHH!!
See, I'm doing....
Ok so girlfriend. We are so good job
View is incredible
You're gonna get in trouble *giggles*
Troubles coming fuck us to the sun's like to Iran songs that kids two years old
Is very tough about?
Where is it goes fuck you
Markiplier  faust? Oh my God see you stupid Chinese guy?
Huh, I know your name monkeys. We remember that name
Marc Cairo
Alright, let's just do a time you guys
Tensley a blue hair guy with my glasses as you know about that guy
We become small start mark Carla or something just like this this era
Channel suck
Those like both the funniest and the cringiest thing I've ever seen in my entire life
I am subscribing. Oh
That's so funny!XD
Jeez oh that's a nice one markiplier fan art. Oh, that's so nice
I've seen some of this, but I don't think I've seen all of it. Oh, that's a good one. That's a classic
That's the original piece of fan art that is my channel icon
If you recognize that head that's what my channel icon is and has been for years
oh
Classic so happy oh this stuff is good
Oh this stuff is good this person wolf Jedi Samuel
I think I remember the name is ooh fucking look oh my God. I've seen this one boy. It's so cool
Oh handsome Devil. Hey handsome Devil
Oh my God, lady that one look at this one. Look at this one. Oh the pinterest thing ooh hello
Look at that one. Oh
Oh, this is uh this one of the one this is their baby
This is stupid me, but you know they made uh yeah that was made by the person that also did the tour?
Poster art and did an amazing job at it
It's a Vicarano!
Yeah,"VickoRano" does amazing work and she actually made the tour art
Hahahaha, oh I remember gremble. Oh, oh man. That was actually just recently what am I remembering it was just happening. There is also
I bet if we go over back a few things. There's the markiplier fans devianart
This has existed since pretty much the beginning of my channel and has been the one place to go that I go to
For fan art! If you have fan art that you want everyone or me to see and you have a devianart hosted here
I also in rien rating my subreddit if you want to go there check that out post it up vote it
I want to see all of it
I wanna and I want to start putting into videos again cuz you got like this timeline
You can actually go and see all of it way back in the past what what is that? Well back in the pajama stream
Oh, oh, I wish oh. I wish look at that balls
oh, ho ho,HOHO!!
Oh shit. Oh yeah, ReR Deadight
ReR Deadight was one of the first people to like really get into the darkiplier fan art, and. Oh my God. Yeah
I've seen so much of this stuff ah they do such good work. Yeah, but it's just it's really cool
There's so much history here
It's so much fan art so that's been posted, and you know it's something that I really love good stuff. Good stuff. Good stuff
Markiplier x
OHHOHOHOHOHO
That went down a rabbit hole real quick. I don't know what lemon means,
But, I'm gonna....
I'm gonna back off on that one
Markiplier memes
exactly what everybody always
wanted
Yes, oh
Ha ha ha ha look at this meme guys ha ha ha oh
Ha ha ha oh man
oh
I know right so relatable ha ha ha ha ha it's not
It's not one of those relatable meme. I'm not 100% sure ah
Ehhhhhhhhhhh....
oh my God herb was
Herrblore *repeating tries*
Herb-lore it's such a weird word herblore
Herblore it starts becoming a word *repeating yet again*
boy, oh
Herrblore
HeRBlORRE
Herblore!!
*Dying cow noise*
*yet again repeating attempts*
Just say it! Herb lore! Say it!
Hablar larla??????markipier.exe has crashed*
Markiplier
birthday
That's it. That's my birthday
And that is a good one to end on! So, thank you everybody who has joined me this far on my birthday!
I don't know if there's gonna be posing on the same day or every day but thank you for watching us. I google myself
is Markiplier an engineer?
The answer is NOOOO!!
Anyway, so that was fun I Googled myself. Go Google yourself
Maybe you'll find something interesting! So, thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you thought down the comments below and.....
As always, I will see YOU in the next video!
Bye-bye! ('v-)